Alright guys, are you guys ready for the spooky time?
Because I'm not fucking ready.
I'm not fucking ready.
Oh god.
Let me turn, let me close the music.
This is time to close the music chat.
And...
Oh god.
This is too loud.
My dad came back with bubble tea.
So I'm gonna scream.
green mcbubble tea in my head
oh god I hate all of you I hate this I hate this oh god
continue story yes oh god may the odds ever be in your favor
ready for the speed when you're right you're right I
shouldn't be scared I'm gonna finish this in 10 minutes chat
ready for the last 10 minutes of this game oh shit is that
we're back alright where are you Oh shit.
Hey Teddy.
Okay, let me fix the settings.
Oh my gosh.
I hate how this looks.
I need to fix the sensitivity.
Okay.
I'm baby.
Why are I allowed to add some welding?
Oh god.
She seems so sad and desperate.
You don't think I... Oh!
Oh my god!
I... I... Sorry, I...
oh gosh i mean okay we're just okay anyway chat we just
start we're starting the game now damn i gee thank you so
much for the follow
anyway i'm a butter thank you um shit what do you mean i
fell what do you mean that was like part of the loading
screen i don't know what you're talking about chat don't be
stupid that was part of the loading screen guys I that's not
true yeah I'm I just load into the game guys what the fuck
do you mean I just load into the game what the fuck are we
stupid chat I can't believe I I fell there that was part of
the loading cutscene oh yeah I didn't do that No, she, yeah,
I didn't die.
She just, yeah, I was, no, no, that was just the loading
screen.
It was a cutscene, child.
It was a cutscene.
I didn't even control a baby.
Thank you so much for the fallow beans.
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh, oh shit.
I mean, I have a blood heart.
Okay.
God, this is one, this is the last level, guys.
last level it was pot yeah it was supposed to happen guide
clearly you guys have never played this game before it's
canon exactly exactly
i need to hydrate before i go in let me hide get some tears
in me first get some tears in me before i cry it all out I
choked on water.
There's too many tears.
Oh, God.
I hate this.
I'm so fucking hate this.
Okay.
All right.
I'm processing.
Oh, God.
What is this?
What?
Why is this so dark?
No!
I hate this.
He'll be playing his kids with her babies.
Oh, this is so dark.
Oh, God.
Hi.
Ah.
How do I get out of here?
Why are there puzzles?
I can't.
Wait, how do I get Teddy out?
I forgot the controls.
How do I get him out?
Teddy.
What?
How do I get Teddy out?
Oh, guys.
Guys, how do I get Teddy?
Was it F?
Oh, Teddy.
Teddy.
That's right, Teddy.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
It's a puzzle.
it's a puzzle everything oh god I hate this I hate this baby
slowly walk baby walk oh god what is oh god I'm getting
goosebumps already let me let me fucking turn off the volume
just a tiny bit more oh my god sheer heart attack 20 I think
it's so much worth the follow Thank you.
Thank you.
Have a butt hurt.
Thank you so much.
I forgot the climbing sound.
I hate it whenever he has to climb.
I hate this.
I hate the sound when he's climbing.
I want to go back to art.
I want to draw again.
I want to draw.
Take me back to art.
Oh, God.
Oh.
I don't want to open the door.
Please don't make me open the door.
Oh,
I just go back here.
Oh, okay.
What happened?
What the fuck?
I love thank you so much for the follow thank you I love
butter thank you okay how do I get up up God I just want him
to oh god I hate this
you got it right thank you oh what did I break I'm sorry!
Why?
I'm sorry, I'm so sorry.
Please, I'm so sorry.
I am so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry for breaking some...
Hey, Easter egg.
I'm so sorry.
So sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, God.
I hate this.
You didn't miss anything.
Felicity!
Thank you so much for the rain.
Oh, let me go under a table.
Let me go under a table before I say anything.
I'm going to get straight, Felicity.
Thank you for the rain.
I'm safe under this table.
I am safe.
I gotta be safe when I thank people for raids, but thank
you.
I hope you had a good stream Play Warframe.
Okay.
All right.
I got this Baby strong
Felicity oh god Felicity thank you for the tier one for five
woods
Holy shit you get some bark night's real great for Felicity.
I've been I hope you're doing well with your research paper.
I am dying as a I'm dying, but but it's oh god, please
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry Please don't hurt me
Thank you, Alipam.
Thank you.
I'm laughing out my pain right now.
I'm so sorry.
It's so hard for me.
I didn't miss no.
You didn't miss anything.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
What?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
What happened?
Okay, Easter egg.
Pain.
Everything.
All I feel is pain.
I don't know what just happened.
Did I open this door?
Easter egg.
Oh!
Did I get fall damage?
What was that?
Give me a walkthrough and take me out of this hell.
it's not this why don't I show up and we can live through it
oh god why did it give me a maze why do I have a maze
I don't know I don't even know what's happening I don't even
know what's going on
oh god oh god just You speed boost amp it up.
Baby crawl?
Baby crawl.
Where can I crack this?
This is where I'm in need of.
Oh god, I was, oh my god.
The real monster was me all along.
What the fuck are your shadow is this?
It's always the shadows.
do i fall baby fall baby fall oh shit what the fuck baby
obviously has a gopro oh key what is this key bullshit when
holding a use none to throw it none to throw it what do you
mean none to throw it what
None!
Alright.
None to throw it.
Okay, up here?
Is it not?
No, it was right click.
What the fuck?
Nice and nice air.
Dude.
Baby smoy.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Oh, I'm so- Oh, God!
I'm so sorry!
I can't see me.
I'm safe.
If I can't see you, you can't see me.
It's okay.
We don't have to keep playing.
I'm safe.
I'm in my safe space.
I'll be behind.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Like, get along the sleeve up yep here I am here I am open
sesame okay baby smart oh kind okay
what's this is puzzles oh shit she's singing why are you
singing why is your I had very many of these spells of
hypermorning and anxiety when I was a kid and I still can't
explain properly
Oh, guy.
I hate this.
I want to look at a walk for right now.
You hear that was that?
No, I did not, Bear.
I didn't even hear that now that you said it.
Why did you have to say shit, Bear?
Because I didn't hear it.
Why did they want me to climb up?
oh god please i have enough stuff to worry about i have
enough stuff to worry about now you're giving me puzzles i'm
a baby here i'm a baby what are our towels i'm fucking uh
200 what
you think a baby knows how to do oh god boys A little little
baby gonna do puzzles exactly
But mine was a dumb baby What dumb as fuck baby Oh wait no
I'm smart God I'm so fucking smart Look at that
Baby is Gordon Freeman You can do puzzles when you're too
free God I don't know what I'm scared of I don't know why
can I be What am I scared of over now what is it i don't
even know what that is
why are you scared baby what happened baby what's going on
okay okay time to breathe time to breathe okay baby's
breathing baby's alive because he's breathing
but I'm baby okay where is this lead me where are you taking
me oh guy a baby oh oh guy I
love you I love you please don't leave me
If I stare at this corner, nothing can hurt me.
Nothing, nothing can hurt me if I'm in this corner.
Oh my god,
it was...
Oh god
Okay I hate this
I was hitting just about every anxiety trigger I have And
this is not okay Oh my god Felicity I'm sorry I am just as
scared If not fucked up as you are right now With this game
Hey so much for the Apollo Pumpkin Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate how I'm a butthurt.
You cute.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, I am in the kitchen.
I am a small...
Oh, God.
Who's gonna get you, please?
I'm
going, baby climb.
Does baby have to climb right now?
Where does baby have to...
Oh, God.
I have to knock this down.
Don't worry baby can do baseball
Let me in, I'm so sorry.
Let me in.
Let me in Why can't I close the door?
Why can't I close the door ?
Okay
Okay I'm okay Oh my god, I get out.
I'm okay.
Baby's okay.
Baby, boy, they're okay.
Please, let me close.
Let me close.
I just, can I just, like, get my dad to play this game for
me?
I see like, yeah, I'm totally playing this game, guys.
I'm like, you're done.
Can you finish this game for me, dad?
You know what, thanks, dad.
I'll just do a commentary.
I'll pretend.
I'll just be like, oh, shit, that was scary.
Wow, guys.
Wasn't that scary, guys?
I'm totally playing this game right now.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Wait, what happened to my shelf?
Where did you go?
Wait!
Alright, did I run?
Shit, no, do I...
Where's my shelf?
What the heck happened to it?
Where do I go?
Okay.
no wait no hello you're on it's not my morning hello mello i
am crying mello what if we climb oh shit up up um the answer
was in front of us all along
the answer was in front of us all along
Wow, chat.
Wasn't that a great game, guys?
I can't believe we beat it.
This was our objective all along, chat.
Wow, we did it.
See here, we're safe here.
We never had to come out.
We did it.
We beat the game.
Wow.
Holy shit, we...
Congratulations, everyone.
We finished the game.
No need for food.
We have books in a tiny cabinet.
Yep.
We're still good at this video game.
Thanks everyone for coming.
Stupid babies don't starve.
They don't need to eat.
I've never raised a baby before.
I assume they don't need to eat.
eat right i mean we have books in a lab and teddy wait why
can't i bring out teddy teddy oh wait can you stand up we
have books uh okay books teddy and the light babies don't
eat
okay all right all right um they only poop exactly babies
that's why babies are fucking useless What do we need babies
for?
Two titties have no...
Oh my god.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, is this another easter egg?
How do I get up?
How does baby get up?
Oh god, what is this?
What is this?
Oh my god.
Baby, stop drawing on walls!
are these drawings dude okay not gonna lie these are really
good drawings for a fucking child to draw like this oh god
fucking my the ball squeaks in the background from my dog
scared me the ball squeeze actually spooked me out what
the fuck is she okay is her back okay she needs to see a
doctor sorry
i'm sorry for opening the door i'm so sorry i'll never open
doors again what the was that sound
what am i supposed to be afraid of what am i supposed to be
afraid of i don't know
What are we supposed to be afraid of?
And you never open yours yet, I guess.
Don't worry, Minecraft Street.
Squiggly screens, I guess.
Wait, why won't it let me open this?
Oh, God.
Oh god, what is this ambience?
Oh, maybe there's one more juice box.
I hate this so much.
I...
Please, I just want to get... Please, just... Just chase me.
Just, just, just... Just take me out already, mister.
Just...
Please.
Well, I don't know where you are, Mr. Monster.
Just.
I hate this.
Please no more ambience, please.
Where do I go?
God, don't make me.
Don't make me go through this.
There's so many bottles.
What the fuck is baby supposed to do with all these bottles?
Wait.
Okay, wait, wait.
I got this.
okay all right watch this i'm not gonna knock down anything
one watch this pro gamer move baby skinny enough for this oh
god oh god don't you dare fall don't you dare fall i think
i'm stuck guys no no i'm fucked up i am so sorry i'm fucked
up oh Close the door!
Whoa!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, guys!
I saw her how to close this!
I don't know how to close it.
I don't know how I lived.
I just saw the closet.
He's walking the way.
He just walked away.
He actually just, he just walked away.
He am alive.
I don't know.
Okay.
You know what?
There's the other door.
we're okay okay all right so what we learned today what we
learned is slow and steady with zo race all right there's no
more bottles there's no more bottles the cat hurt us there's
no bottles cat hurt me there's no more ball okay let me open
this let me let me open you why is there just a chair?
Why is there just a chair right here?
What the fuck?
I'm not going in there.
I'm not gonna go in there.
Why is there just a chair there?
Would you like to take a seat, baby?
I learned how to close the door.
I learned how to do it.
I did it.
What the fuck?
I didn't see any glass.
Where's the glass?
Where did I break?
Where did I break the glass?
Where?
Please.
Explain to me.
I didn't.
I'm like slowly walking here.
And they're like, yep, you broke glass.
Like, okay, you know what, fuck this?
Oh my god!
How the fuck am I going to pass this?
Excuse me?
This one glass bottle here?
Yeah, but where do I run to?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Just run?
Okay, okay, okay.
No, I got this.
I'm not a fool.
I'm not gonna touch you.
I'll be it, I'll be it, I'll be it, I'll be it, I'll be it
I'll be it All right Oh my god, please
Where do I go?
Dude, fuck this maze shit
Nadia, thank you so much for the follow Thank you, thank you
Thank you.
Where do I even go?
Dude, not only are they giving me bottles.
They, what the, is that just a shoe?
Okay, I was gonna be like, not only, um, dude, I, I'm a
baby.
That's the premise.
I'm a fucking baby trapped in hell.
Like, I don't even know.
Not only do they, do they, do they have bottles.
I had to hide from them.
monster and they have to give me a maze like what the fuck
is what i'm just a fucking baby just give me one not 20 of
these things like i don't know where to go oh there's a
bottle
you play a baby exploring a dream like while evading yo
that's a better explanation than me all i said was like i'm
a i'm a fucking baby trapped in hell I'm scared there's fall
damage, so I'm just gonna...
Boop.
Won't be fucked up if you gave a baby fall damage too.
They open.
Oh god.
Where's the memory?
Okay, okay, I'm safe in the memory.
I'm safe.
I'm safe in memories.
Memory is safe.
Please!
Memory is safe!
save.
I swear a monster come here.
How does the baby even end up in?
I don't know.
Baby did a bad thing.
We got the final memory.
Let's hurry.
Hurry where?
I have to run?
Oh god.
Oh no, it's here.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Am I here?
Baby, run.
Baby, fucking run.
Baby, please run faster, baby.
Baby?
Baby.
Oh, God.
Please, please, get it.
No, no, no.
No.
Oh, God.
That was the...
Yeah, dude, I don't give a fucking bear bear.
You can take him.
Please, just take the bear.
I don't care.
Let's just take the bear.
Oh, God.
Oh, no!
I thought you met on my ass today's...
You should just let him take the bear, you stupid baby.
Well, at least we know there's no fall damage.
At least we know there's no fall damage.
There he has no heart.
Give me light, light.
You guys get it too.
I'll make a traumatizing game.
baby oh baby run baby run let me just look at you right
you'll get what you want which I didn't know you know baby's
about oh hey mom hey there hey mom hey mom please oh she's
an alcoholic okay mom's an alcoholic okay all right at least
we know that.
Mom's an alcoholic.
Mom is an alcohol.
Please, baby, please.
Baby.
It's
like, you can't hurt me.
You can't hurt me.
I'm like, it will not take you.
What mommy says.
Mommy, I'm sorry.
Mommy, I'm sorry, please.
Oh god, please, please baby, you're faster than this.
You made me please, you're faster.
I'm sorry.
Did she just say I will find you?
What?
You scared the bottom of me if I die, run here because he
thought someone was being killed.
Technically...
Technically I was...
I was dying mentally.
I was getting killed in my mind.
It's okay, we don't need Teddy anymore.
We don't need him.
It's all... It's you and me chat.
All I need is just chat.
Who the fuck gives a fuck about?
Who gives a...
Am I stuck?
Wait.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh shit, no, I'm sorry I fucked up.
Wait, I'm stuck
Wait, I broke the game.
I broke the game I can't even I can't even turn the wheel
how did I'm trying dude, okay chat I am trying I actually
broke the game Wait, oh no I can't turn the wheel it won't
let me turn it I can't until I broke the game.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I kind of didn't.
I can't even exclamation point.
Wait.
I actually broke the game.
I can't.
How do I fuck up that badly?
How do I control?
Did I do it?
How do I fuck up?
I can't.
It won't let me turn it.
wheels my natural it won't i can't even press escape chat i
had to i actually broke the game holy it won't let me turn
the wheel oh god where is i actually oh my god i actually
chat if i restart this is it oh please don't make me replay
this part i get No, please, let me turn the wheel.
I'm so sorry I didn't mean anything I say.
I'll save Bear.
I'll save the Bear.
I love Bear.
I love the Bear.
I'm so sorry.
Please let me turn the wheel.
No!
Oh, no.
It won't let me do escape.
I can't even pull up my options.
Alright, game.
I'm so sorry.
I can't even open the chest.
Okay, at least mom can't find me again.
Alright, chat, let me.
I have to restart the game.
I can't believe I broke the game.
I actually can't believe I broke it during this.
stage what can i not do chat what can i not do can't turn a
wheel apparently holy i just i just don't know how to turn
wheels well i'll be right back i'm gonna well i will still
be here i'm just gonna i'm just gonna restart the game i
guess because i'll just restart the oh my god i guess i'll
just restart the game oh my god dude where is it gonna take
me oh my i'm so sad i swear if it makes me do level again.
The nightmare being recursive is part of the requirement.
Oh, God.
I have to go through this.
Where is this going to restart me?
Where are you going to restart me?
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
It's here.
Oh, thank God.
It restarts me here.
Dookies laugh.
Make me dookie dookie.
Oh, God.
thank you I'll close the door you do maybe it's because I
didn't close the door holy shit I was I was gonna be like
where are you gonna restart me game okay all right I won't
break it this time
oh god I did see that I can open this chest too okay now I
can open this chest too boom boom wait how do I do this if I
click it really fast maybe i can do it but oh god is it
gonna make me go out is it gonna make me go out did the f
block oh i don't need teddy i don't need teddy i have the f
block i'll just put this on top who needs teddy when i have
blocks okay that didn't work okay maybe i do need teddy okay
I was gonna say we don't need we don't need him I lied we
don't need him I just why is your arms there's a baby is
actually some drunk dude running and hiding from cops aka
monster okay all right yeah we have book and lamp and that's
all okay I swear I can just get this lamp and then just put
it on there should be another ending where we leave without
Teddy because I would take that ending.
I would take the ending without Teddy.
Like, fuck him.
Like, if I could get an ending without him, I'll fucking
take it.
Oh, God.
Where do I even go?
Is it?
Just head straight?
I hate this.
I don't even know where to go.
Oh, God.
Run, so what?
I'm gonna make you so much more fun.
Thank you.
I see a dead end.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't know where to go.
Baby go up?
Where's up?
Where is up?
Where?
Where does baby go?
I'm back here
puppies what if oh I get it right right
see I don't need Teddy I don't need him I have his arm I
don't need him I have his fucking arm who the fuck needs him
No, baby, never go down.
Who the fuck needs him?
I have a fucking arm.
That's all I need.
How the hell would anyone figure that out?
Hang him back home.
Nothing to work.
Stop crying, little baby.
You have an arm.
Teddy was the only constant and you needed a friend to solve
the last puzzle.
Fuck Teddy, we don't need Teddy.
All I have is arm.
All I need was his arm.
Oh god, it's getting darker.
I don't like that.
I don't like that it's getting darker guys.
Oh god.
Hey Teddy.
You need my teddy back.
Stay away from me.
Oh god, please.
I don't even want him.
I never meant to.
I don't even want Teddy.
What?
Oh shit, hate.
Look, can I look at her?
Dude, she's a terrible mom.
Like, what the fuck?
Let's go into the light.
Hi there, little one.
Come here.
Did you like your gift?
Oh, is that dad?
Hey, dad.
Is that acid?
I don't know.
Acid.
I'm sorry to hear.
What?
I think it's getting less like it relates to this.
Yeah.
Oh.
We did it.
We finished the game.
Holy shit.
We did it.
beat the game.
I'm so proud.
We did it, chat.
We did it together.
We didn't fucking need Teddy.
All we needed was this fucking arm.
I don't have custody now.
Shit, I like how there's like no music at all.
It's just...
Baby did it.
Baby went up.
Woo!
We did it, guys!
all baby had to do was go up we spent a whole game carry all
that extra weight when we all need right lesser we didn't
need shit all we needed was fucking arm
and then you had the option to hug her at the end by the way
oh who gives a fuck about her dude
time for no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no holy shit chat
teddy gave his last to let you escape why is there more
appreciation teddy's sacrifice dude teddy didn't do shit he
didn't do like shit this entire game other than giving me
his arm that was like his only benefits throughout that game
oh he was like hey i think hey did you hear that oh my like
after like the thing was gone you're like wow wow baby did
you hear that hear shit but he wants me to hear something
teddy made you go into the wardrobe when he put us in the
mess with us to the start but time for like how are you this
wholesome like how are you wholesome this holy shit though
we chat i can't believe we we beat we beat the game another
scary game under the belt does that say batman what the fuck
wait we Wait, did you guys see that?
It said Batman.
That's the fuck.
Big Andy.
Okay, some of these names are great.
Hmm.
The Andy, dude.
There's no music.
What the fuck?
Wait, let me put some music on in the background while we...
Instead of like this ominous...
Let's have some music.
I mean...
That makes it better, makes it even better allegorically
since, since I missed the beginning.
Yeah, we're, oh, some chill, chill song in the background.
Leave it as this is.
This is like Persona 5 music in the background.
I was like, I can't.
It's so true.
Keep racing to it.
Dark wolf 9 Someone put their fucking Dark wolf 9 Don't keep
baby got a wrinkle on brain Now an extra wrinkle Earn Every
game I finish I earn more wrinkles in my brain Certainly I
have two wrinkles I have finished Two games
But without Teddy We'll be one With
forever just to be smoothed out 20 minutes later the real
teddy was a wrinkle we made all along i honestly did not
think the game was gonna we were gonna uh we were gonna
finish this game so quickly how long did that take us
actually oh shit wait that took us an hour wait that was an
hour of gameplay holy shit i felt like wait sorry i mean 10
minutes sorry sorry i meant Does that took me 10 minutes?
Like so many Daniels.
Why are we still at the...
How long is this credit?
Because we're still...
Oh, now we're at ease.
Okay, we made it to the ease, guys.
Holy shit.
It's from A to...
You know what?
Yeah, we don't need to learn about all the Eddies up there.
Do we have, like, bonus?
Playground in the account.
Museum.
What's this museum?
I was saying that going to all the timely among us the light
in the mood.
We need to see every name.
Alright, let's look at the museum chat.
I like how the Persona 5 music is playing the background
while...
Okay, what the fuck?
Where the fuck are...
Is this Ghost Teddy?
Is he dead?
Wait, did Teddy die?
What?
Wait, so his arm is gone and he's dead?
Take a look around.
Teddy's a ghost now.
Wait, Teddy actually died.
What the fuck?
Teddy is your subcon, Teddy Ghost.
This one's on his sub.
The birth of Among You Sleep.
know dude teddy could have been so cute like this is such a
cute version of teddy sorry my dog is like looking at my dad
and outside teddy is a sacrosanct piece uh the the blunt gun
yeah what was this so fucking dude okay i i hate like i know
this is like textured for 3d but this looks so so oh gosh
Doki no no Doki no come on sorry my dog is Harold Hydra oh
god dude fuck this girl oh so this is a monster
is this a co-monster I don't do fuck this bitch though oh we
never saw like his top half until until the end museum i
want to go to the the gallery the museum gallery oh here it
is here it is show puppy i have a lot of photos of my dog in
the discord i mean oh god prologue was added there's a
prologue you guys want to oh should we play the prologue
guys made in collaboration with some of our bands and made
to elaborate i don't want to play the prologue like we can
play it that the mother was not oh yeah i'm so fast what the
fuck relationships are so fast look at that baby well all
right all right we'll play the prologue after we look at the
museum i drew my nightmare ones look pretty sick it'll be in
my memories in 70 years look forward to it oh gosh oh you're
home my home look at my home the team wanted to start with
oh my god what the fuck of the mother as well as the
mechanics of the game i'm gonna turn off the
Teddy in the form of a gift maybe zoom showing how old the
kid is I don't understand why Teddy has to be a good this is
a side choice a large part of the game is based on how
children see and interpret what's happening go on the
computer oh shit okay the playground well dude fuck the
ground what when what is your birds wait there were birds in
this game what the
what when were there birds in the game what the fuck all i
remember was owl i remember was this i mean that's all i
remember Okay, so these are all the artwork of the
playground.
What is this?
Oh, this is like a diagram.
Patty, and he's laughing, he kind of says, okay.
This is a forested home.
It's a crumbling home that's slowly rotting away into the
water.
He was too scared to notice.
Yeah, I didn't see the fucking burn.
This sum tunnel was unwrapped in sea brush.
Nevertheless, they were happy.
The house here is a symbol of the family and home falling
apart.
heart.
The bloated creature inhabiting it is how the kid sees his
mother when she's drinking and full of sorrow.
Aww.
This is like the designs of the house.
Where's the monsters?
Oh, this is the... Teddy, where are you?
How am I supposed to learn shit without Teddy here?
Wait, what?
What's this?
What the fuck?
Oh, this is the exit.
I was like, what is this?
Where's Teddy?
How am I supposed to learn anything?
Oh, there's the monsters.
Oh, God.
What the?
Who's this?
What?
What the fuck?
Wait, what was this here?
Wait!
We go back, we grab the airplane, and he looked like, wait,
it looked like that?
What the- Wait!
Excuse me!
Yeah, fuck Teddy, dude.
Holy shit!
Okay, wait.
Now this is, I know the story of how the game ended.
It was very different.
In the early...
it was a production back then teddy was antagonist of the
game oh actually kind of something like we don't need teddy
this whole time the lords are so well thought out though
props to the devil yeah the lord is very interesting um and
an evil entity a monster disguised as a friendly teddy bear
took advantage of this by taking the sound child into a
dangerous adventure far away from home um oh it's okay so it
was like that
have to give him black eyes like black eyes is so unself
who's this what the fuck is this guy i know these three or
two who is he they don't remember shit harold harold who are
you i remember him and her oh god dude did i hate holy shit
oh god i don't want to look at her anymore
You completely missed him.
Yeah, I never seen him.
There's mom.
And there's all the plushies.
What are these?
Sleep?
What are you?
There's our very early projections.
There wasn't a sudden decision to cut these.
Oh, they're like...
They're all the cut creatures that were supposed to be in
this game.
what's this
I'm guessing he's a monster and a player on stage but we
never met him because of tech gun plays yeah is that oh my
god what the fuck is excuse me
well okay I'm getting out of here what the fuck was that
okay like oh oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry what's over here
wait i've
all right teddy goes top this is the reveal this is where
you see your mother for what she is and the player gets to
connect the various monsters and sights through the game oh
okay wait okay look what what are you gonna say ah my
favorite place I felt we really connected here you know a
bit of a breather between the various bad nightmarish worlds
we went to also I was able to talk a lot here as elsewhere
the developers were concerned about keeping the tension up
and didn't want me to learn me now how scared also is it
scary get quiet when scared, so it's okay and all, but I
like the best the times we had to catch up.
Where's this area?
He talked to me.
Originally, the chase for the mom was a MacGuffin.
You did not really find her, and the monsters used her to
lure you further into the dream lands.
Oh, I see.
And we struggled for some time to make sense of this story,
especially the playtesters confused as the story ended
without you seeing your mom again.
I don't even get out here.
proceed to see the old ending of among the sleep oh shit now
here is something truly special what is the old name want to
see what the game almost was at some point this is an old
version of the story's conclusion and it's been something we
have not shown anybody except a few testers in the early
days you might say here I got to have more fun than in the
original ending Oh, is this where he becomes, like, an evil
guy?
Come in and see.
Okay.
Oh, oh, God.
This is the original ending.
Oh, God.
What is this?
Oh,
I move?
Oh, I can move.
Oh, okay, but that's it.
I can't do shit.
Okay.
Okay, there's Teddy.
Here's evil Teddy.
He still hates me fear.
Oh, is he gonna...
Oh, he's gonna cook me.
Oh, there's...
Hey, Teddy.
Teddy.
Where did you go, Teddy?
Where did you go?
Teddy?
Oh, what do I do?
Oh, oh, God.
Wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
It did.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Oh, it's him.
Oh god!
I hate this!
Bring me back!
I'm so sorry!
Please!
Whoa
guys!
Whoa!
Oh!
Okay, yeah.
Okay, the longer serum the less scary gets not gonna lie uh
you know what he reminds me of he reminds me of the
SpongeBob Grandma from the chocolate episode?
Like yeah you like yeah you like grandma in the soy
chocolate sea yeah the more I look at him the more I realize
you know it's not that scary the more I get chocolate
Give him some chocolate.
Let him keep up with this.
This guy watched SpongeBob, that's for sure.
Look he's singing us a song before he eats us.
Isn't that sweet?
Me.
Please just eat me, dude.
I'm okay.
Oh, God.
Very thoughtful of him.
Very thoughtful of him for him to sing us a lullaby before
he fucking goes home with us.
I worked it so I still love it.
Bye bye.
Sing me a lullaby before you eat me.
Kind of split- yeah how he's- but you know you guys just
chuck us into the can?
But he was like...
he's like i'm gonna make it i'm gonna make it less painful i
see on point why i would eat a baby unless the baby had some
i mean i mean you eat baby some people eat baby chickens and
baby deer
it's like saying why would you eat a baby what i mean early
horror games were more in jump scares right and low yeah i
like the hell there's lore here it's very interesting all
right let's the prologue, guys.
How long is the prologue?
I hope it's not super long.
Can I just fall in?
Oh, no.
Why don't I?
How do I get out?
Oh, fast, baby.
You know what?
Oh, this is how you get out.
I was like, how do I get out?
Alright, let's try the prologue, guys.
Um.
Alright.
I'm gonna see how long I'm gonna look up how long the
prologue is guys before we play it how long it is among the
sleep prologue just so just so I know all right I'm complete
okay 15 minutes so that's like one hour I mean no we're
gonna speed beside like five five minutes for me if it's if
it takes 15 minutes to complete it it's practically five
minutes for me easy We got this five minute speed run.
Let's fucking go You're probably yeah exactly probably clear
in five minutes chat
Why am I in the fucking why the fuck did they put the baby
in the snow?
Baby, why are you in snow?
Where the fuck left the baby in the snow?
What the fuck?
Oh god, what?
Teddy where's Oh, it's a prologue.
I haven't had my birthday yet.
I haven't had my birthday.
Cold.
So, so cold.
Who said that?
That's not me.
Babies can't, babies can't talk.
Oh!
Hey there.
What do I do?
Hello?
Oh, hello?
Who the fuck do you want me to do?
I'm gonna leave you.
Dude, fuck you.
Oh, wait, I was gonna...
I thought I had to open that and leave.
I was gonna...
I thought...
I didn't think it was clue.
I thought I was gonna go outside.
I was gonna go leave you.
all right
here enter this is what you want oh oh safe thank you
monsters don't like happy monsters don't like happy yeah
fuck happiness dude
Oh, please help them.
Warm, good, cold, bad.
I haven't seen Press the teddy button.
Nothing.
I can't do anything with the teddy button.
Oh, can I open the door?
Oh, I can.
I have to go up.
Maybe up.
Oh, why is it dark?
Hello.
Oh, oh, wait, why are you back?
Can't see me, can't see me, we don't need daddy, mom, can't
see me.
Oh,
I'll just go this way.
Oh, gosh.
Step five, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I love, humble butthard, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where the fuck do I...
Is this another maze?
Please.
Not another maze.
Oh!
Lore!
Thank you, LF.
Lore.
Oh, God.
Sorry about me.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a good heart.
Thank you so much.
How many plushies do I have?
Okay, but...
Where are these?
a plushies.
Please don't make me try and find them.
Please don't give me a maze.
Do, do, do, do.
Can I hear me?
I'm okay.
Gotta find them.
Do, do, do.
Ah!
I'm baby.
Hey, mom.
Hey, there.
Oh, mom gone.
Please.
Mom, gone.
Okay.
What do you mean?
How do you even get up?
How do I even get up?
Oh, up.
That's how.
That's how I get up.
I better get up from here.
Oh, I don't need to get up, right?
Okay.
excuse me excuse me County Sir how do I close a window how I
don't know I do a lot of things apparently I'm a very dumb
baby I'm so sorry man I'm so sorry I'm very dumb I don't
know I don't know how to close windows I don't know how to
close windows
Wait, can I move chair?
Oh, I can move the chairs.
Look, I died.
Oh, shit.
I'm a very dumb baby.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, happiness.
What makes you happy?
Happy, please.
I don't know what makes you happy.
Wait, wait.
See?
Knife?
Okay, definitely not the knife.
A ball.
Oh, that is not a ball.
Oh, God.
Wait, I fucked up.
I don't think I was supposed to pick that up, guys.
I don't think I was supposed to pick that up.
I was supposed to pick that up.
I caused my own.
I actually caused my own.
I almost like myself over.
Okay, so what I learned was that I was not that.
What makes you happy?
Oh, maybe?
Does this make me happy?
Okay, where the fuck is your shit that makes you happy?
Open?
Okay, where are you?
What makes you happy?
Okay, well...
What makes you happy, mister?
Make happy.
I'm trying to figure this shit.
Dude, my brain is so tiny right now.
I don't know what the fuck would make you happy.
this guy happy oh
that does not make happy
okay okay but where was I supposed to bring the music box
warmth makes him happy okay let me go back let me go back
there has to be some happy things here oh wait the fridge Is
there happy things in here?
Okay, nothing in here looks happy.
What if we turn on the stove?
Oh, true.
Okay, no, you cannot turn on the stove.
There is nothing.
There's nothing there, or I can turn.
Dude, what the fuck makes you happy?
You're not helpful at all, mister.
I don't know what makes you happy.
Does milk make you happy?
Ooh, is it milk?
No, I can't pick it up.
Oh, I can.
does milk make you happy mr.
mr.
does milk make you happy
that's a milk okay i don't think he wants milk how the fuck
does this person finish this in 15 minutes it was not milk
it was not milk
what make happy
do you what make happy
what was that i'm so sorry i'm so sorry oh oh how do i make
happy you're fantastic
How do you make happy?
I've been stuck here trying to...
Oh, shit.
Wait, play?
Let's play make happy.
Plane.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, baby.
Thank you so much.
I don't follow.
Thank you.
Are you got play?
Does play make happy?
Oh.
Okay, it's not playing.
We don't know how to make happy I'm gonna think here what
makes you Okay, we're like stuck in this one level cuz we
don't know how to fuck we make happy Well, we don't know how
we We're gonna be stuck here forever.
We don't know how to make happy
Oh god.
Oh god monster.
I'm so sorry let me hide Honorable he is so under the tier
one 16 months.
Thank you.
Woo.
And get some break nights real quick for Audible.
Do I have to go back?
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know how to make happy.
Wait.
Karma?
Maybe there's happy here.
Happy?
Anything happy here?
Any happy times?
Okay.
That's not.
happy time banana find happy oh it makes happy I don't know
I've been trying to figure out happy for so long I'm so oh
please please where do I hide this
makes me happy what makes me happy
okay what
makes you happy okay remote
what makes happy oh remote makes happy thank you
Okay, remote makes happy.
Okay, then where's the fuck?
And this was a good memory.
I'm so...
I'm supposed to be a happy space.
What the fuck?
I thought I was supposed to be a happy place.
I like this stream.
That did not make me happy.
That was not happy.
That was not...
What?
What is that?
Why?
Oh, that monster went in.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
There's Harold.
Hey, Harold.
Can, can he?
I guess we're not going back there.
Well, I guess we know we're not going back this way.
Can I go here?
Is he gonna move?
Dude, so what makes happy in kitchen then?
If I do this, would I die?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
oh my god please wait i need to go back and figure out how
to make happy again
i'm still trying to figure out how to i'm gonna go back i'm
gonna figure out how to fuck do we make this guy happy.
Like, what is it?
What could it be?
It has to be something here.
Yeah.
Also, Ginger, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
It has to be something in here, then.
What makes you happy?
Oh, wait.
Thanks, T2.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I have some butthards.
We're trying to figure out happiness.
The secret to happiness right now.
It was not playing.
I didn't know.
I did.
I looked at the table.
It wasn't table.
Yo, you still...
What makes you happy, bear?
Radio!
It's radio!
That's gotta be it.
Radio.
Okay.
How do I get up, though?
It's radio.
It has to be radio.
Radio equals music.
Music equals...
It's radio.
radio no no you got a butt heart it's even better because I
can't make a proper heart and it looks like a butt I did it
it was radio all along now where did the bear go oh there oh
the fox go there you go it was a fox all along I made him
happy go back to the we go okay all we need is teddy right I
don't like the squeak in me when you grab it sorry my dog is
growling right now you're gonna hear my dog growl
hey mom
I don't like that
sorry please stop making sounds please Oh, he's on me, he's
house.
I'm sick.
Where did I go?
Was that just lore?
Did I not have to go here?
Was it just lore?
Do I go outside?
Well, I'm not gonna go outside anymore.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm not gonna go outside.
What the fuck is that sound?
Wait, what is that sound?
Who gives a fuck about the outside?
Not me.
Okay, I hate this.
I hate it.
Let me in!
Let me
in!
Please!
Oh my god, please!
Let me in!
Oh!
Never!
Harold, I'm sorry, Harold.
I'm sorry, Harold!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry, Harold!
I'm so sorry!
Harold, no, Harold!
Harold gone!
Bye, Harold.
How did I open this?
Bye, Harold!
It's stupid.
wait i think i'm back where i started
i'm back where i start wait where do i fuck do i go you're
gonna play say goodbye before you leaving well i finished
the game i i finished it guys
well look I did it.
I
don't know where to go.
Oh, up?
Oh!
Up!
Baby, go up.
Baby dead.
Oh, baby.
Oh, wait.
Baby, no.
Go up!
Apparently, I guess he doesn't know how to do stairs too.
god at least he doesn't know how to oh i get it that
computer room remember that computer room earlier but where
was the computer room again i don't even remember i don't
i'm so lost guys i don't remember where the computer
memories happy that's okay baby happy for now i just need to
go to the computer room again i need to remember how to get
there i think it was like here somewhere.
Yeah, it was like here.
Right?
Yeah.
This must be where he is, right?
What?
Where did baby go?
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Did I break the- what?
Did I break the game?
What?
Wait, did I break the game?
Excuse me?
Wait, wait, wait, what?
Wait, wait, what?
I think I broke the game.
Where am I?
I broke the game.
How did I break the game?
All I did was just climb up a chair.
All I did was...
It was I climb up the chair and then I broke the cave
because I can't climb chairs too.
I don't want to restart it guys.
It was the roll of the chair.
Okay, load from last checkpoint.
Let's see where it takes me.
Okay, happy times.
Woo!
Back in the kitchen.
Okay.
Back in the kitchen, I go.
Alright, lore.
Woo!
Lore.
Back in here we go.
Yeah, lore.
Hey, Cryptic.
Oh, God!
I'm so sorry!
Harold!
Bye, Harold.
Bye.
Please open the door.
Open the door, lady.
All right, back.
All right, let's get on the chair again.
Oh, my God, Gumi.
Thank you so much for the host.
I don't...
Gumi, thank you for the host, Gumi.
Were you streaming earlier?
Gumi, I hope you had a good...
on center.
Great Christ.
Hello, everyone.
Hey, Reaper.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Have a good blood heart.
Okay.
Um.
Where's the key?
Key, where you at?
Hello, everyone.
From Goombie's stream.
Hello, hello, hello.
You are streaming no game.
Wait, what?
What's Goombie's stream?
Whoa.
Thank you so much for the follow, Hannah.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
She fell asleep!
Thank you so much, Apple Butter.
Hello everyone from Gumi Stream.
I am...
Um...
I am trying to...
What was she...
What was she streaming?
She fell asleep?
Yeah, she passed out.
What was she streaming?
I'm trying to figure out where the fuck the key is just so
that I am baby.
Um, I am a...
I am fucking baby right now.
I don't know what I don't know where to go look there's a
plane ticket I'm a baby on on the fucking desk right now I'm
stuck on this one level baby doesn't know where to go guys
check the drawers the drawers are like climbing things
they're not they're not like and there's nothing in the
drawers they're You're only used for to climb.
I would know, because I've climbed many, many dorms.
Love you.
Thank you so much for the follow and sad boy.
Thank you.
Have a, have a butthard.
Hope you guys enjoyed Gumi's stream.
Hope you guys enjoyed her streams.
I was watching both streams until Gumi found...
Did she, like, was she playing in the middle of Among Us?
And then, and then, and then she fell asleep right in the
middle of the game.
Oh.
Oh my god, that's like...
Oh my god, Gumi.
Oh, that's pretty funny.
That's pretty funny.
Hang on, baby.
I'm stuck on the... Dude.
I want to be back.
Dude, I want to be back in the...
I don't know where to go, guys.
Where does...
Where do they want me to go?
I'm just a fucking baby.
Where you... Where's Harold?
Where's...
zero she didn't fall asleep she just laid back and started
watching undertale dog on her phone and forgot about the
game oh my god oh that's so that's hilarious that's actually
pretty funny i'm like stuck on this level because i have no
idea where to go i don't know where the fuck to find the key
we're free of stream yeah we hit her i was gonna be back
here until herald passed me by um hey maybe harold knows
where the key you think harold knows where the key is let me
go ask harold real quick okay chat all right who wants a
backseat game for me right now any backseaters chat any i
have no shame any backseaters want to come in and help me
right now
Please, please, please, this is why one time I will allow
backseat gaming.
Harold?
Paul, thank you so much for the follow.
I do appreciate it.
Have a, have a butthart.
Thank you, thank you.
Are we supposed to go upstairs?
No, I need a key, though.
I need a key to go upstairs, but I don't know where the key
is.
Oh, wait, Harold, I'm sorry, Harold.
Bye, Harold.
Hey Harold
Please I'm stupid chat Please you know I'm stupid Chat You
know I'm stupid Gerald do you know where the key is?
Thank you so much for the follow Vane, Arjun and Yen Thank
you, thank you, I do appreciate it Hello Bloodheart, thank
you so much Hello Fox, welcome, welcome Thanks, Harold.
Harold doesn't know, I guess.
I'm stupid.
Chad, I'm stupid.
I need all the help I can get.
I'm so stupid.
I'm sorry.
Harold doesn't know.
I don't know.
I've been stuck in this level for 20 years.
Hey, I'm back here.
Hey, welcome back.
you so much with the follow thank you thank you i really do
appreciate it apple blood heart thank you okay chat so so i
guess we just live here i guess we just live here oh my god
okay what happened to this chair how did i fuck up the chair
how did i break the chair
okay maybe
ghost and shab thank you so much with the follow thank you
thank you thank you have some blood hearts thank you so much
guys thank you everyone so yeah i've been stuck in this
particular level for 20 years because i have no idea where
the key is oh hey that's outside
wait wait is the key up here oh my god is the key up here oh
my god okay there's no no it's not i thought i was i thought
i was so smart I honestly thought I was so fucking smart
it's just pens it's just it's just pens thank you guys thank
you everyone for the follows all right so um I guess we're
never gonna I guess we're gonna live here forever now
remember when I said this game only take this level only
takes 15 minutes to complete well then No, I can get up.
I can open these drawers to climb up.
Remember when I said this is a 15-minute level?
Well, uh...
About that.
Gumi is alive.
Did Gumi wake up?
Did she wake up, chat?
Alright, time.
Wait.
We'll get out.
Liquid.
Oh god.
Is that him?
Is that Harold?
Liquid.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a blood heart.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate.
Well then.
When is where Gumi Pukemo will one day be finished?
I just have so much stuff to do lately.
I've had a lot of shit to do.
So we haven't had time to actually actually work on it.
Where the fuck is the key guys?
I hear it on other people later stream.
Oh, shit.
You know what, I'm just gonna go back upstairs.
Maybe, maybe.
She's never asleep, but you're like, hi, but that good, she
was asleep.
She, okay.
Where the, oh, God, please.
Where's the key?
Where are you?
Ah!
Let me in.
Please let me in.
Harold, I hear you.
Harold!
I hear you, Harold.
I don't want to go downstairs because I hear him.
Someone backseat came.
Someone be a hero.
The keys of friends we made along the way.
Oh, God.
Harry, Harold.
marrying them I'll find you oh back here we go hey guys
remember me remember me guys Wow hey I'm back here what's on
the other side of the stairs the other side of the stairs is
just um just toys there's no key down there you know we Oh,
I've been stuck here.
Like, we went here.
We went here.
We went here already.
This is Harold.
This is where we...
Hey, look.
We're back here again.
Welcome back.
How many times have we been here, chat?
How many fucking times have we been here?
oh my god
no we explored the entire house that's the thing can I just
go outside
I'm sorry wait that's the great wait this is locked too why
is everything locked that's the great thank you sin why is
everything locked Please, I don't know what to do.
Oh,
that was me moving the shoes, right?
That's the shoes, right?
Right?
Not Harold?
Oh!
Harold, I'm sorry, Harold.
I'm going to go back in my happy area.
What is this?
I'm so fucking angry.
How do I finish this?
They've been stuck here for 20 years, chat!
Where is it?
Okay, we're gonna...
Alright, okay.
Okay, we got this.
Let me check all the rooms again.
I'm checking everything.
Oh, what's this?
Oh my gosh, this is a fucking door.
This is a door!
It's a fucking door!
We're all stupid!
Let me in!
Baby, y'all had to do was go down!
Baby had to go down!
Light!
Wait, this just killed me?
Oh, this kills me.
Wait, what?
I just went towards the light!
Light!
It said light!
That is light!
Fire hot.
Okay, apparently fire is very hot.
Look.
Hey, look, thank God.
You know, okay, that makes sense, because I was wondering,
like, why am I freaked out about the heater?
Yo, guys, do you guys know fire is bad for babies?
it fire bad budding thank you so much for the follow thank
you thank you you appreciate it how uh hello but heart thank
you so much i'll add my amazon package here late because i'm
about fires i didn't oh my gosh hey today i learned that
that fire is very bad for you oh please
brassy thank you so much for the follow thank you thank you
thank you thank you so much how about but heart thank you
That really sucks though.
That really fucking...
Oh, do I have to...
Fire.
Fire, do I have to come here?
Fire?
Fire!
I have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Look, I need to use my brain.
It took me 20 minutes to find...
Find the stupid...
Dude, please.
I...
Oh, window.
Window.
I was like, what do you want me to do?
to do pause holy shit thank you so much for the tier one 41
month streak whoa that is okay it's okay fire is very far
from me whoa can we get some bark night chill quick for
pulse holy shit he was he was super he was like my super og
og og sub viewer okay okay fire bad fire bad
okay all right
okay okay hey there all right how do i get up do i have to
move this box over it's okay oh whoa whoa please i don't
know how to get up there i'm running oh my god fire back
okay i got the all right I just need to slowly push this
Okay, I thought I could push it all the way What the fuck
Wow, what is that kill range heaters get through quarters
damn this is looking strong-ass heater right here.
I'm sorry heater.
I'm sorry I'm running, please Wait, what the fuck?
The chair's... Wait, what the fuck?
The chair's back there.
Wait, what?
The chair's already back there.
Alright.
Yeah, you think I'm scared of you?
Turn radio on.
Equals happy.
Radio equals happy.
Yeah, that's right.
Thank you.
Get in my stomach.
Okay, now what do I do with this?
Wait, what do I...
Okay, I finished it.
Woo, we finished.
Woo!
Let me know how to shine the way equals happy.
Oh, shit.
Shit, what did you order?
What did you get, Felicity?
Okay, okay.
Okay, baby can't crawl, apparently.
Now it's upstairs open.
It's upstairs open now.
I know it's because the anxiety I have to resolve there.
Oh, no.
You're okay, Felicity.
What the fuck?
Harold?
Does the baby just go... At me?
Oh,
upstairs!
I didn't need a key after all!
I just had to go to the fucking basement!
Wait, I need a key here?
Hey guys!
Harold?
So why are we playing massage?
Never.
Oh!
Oh, let me in!
Let me in!
I don't know how to close it!
Why is it please Harold please don't come in Harold Harold
don't come in I don't know those doors apparently baby dumb
baby stupid oh
fuck here don't come in change it close right now God baby
needs to climb Why are you making baby climb?
Maybe too stupid for that.
Baby dumb.
What the fuck?
Baby go up?
Wait, what?
How do baby go up?
Up.
No chair for me.
Parkour.
Baby parkour apparently.
What the fuck is this?
Stupid shit, baby parkour?
Parkour.
This game is a platformer, right?
Are you- oh, just dumb bitch.
You stupid dumb bunny.
I'm stupid.
Are you dumb as me?
What the fuck?
What am I watching?
We're watching baby right now.
You know what I'm falling out the way that the fuck?
Oh my god.
Harold, is that you, Harold?
Hey, Harold.
What?
What the fuck?
It just blocks me there?
Baby go bye-bye.
Amen.
be about to get the oh my god the dokeyborn let me out let
me out let the baby out baby out baby leave baby leave wait
where the fuck is the doll
bye baby go out he doesn't care anymore baby's leaving I
think you just walked over it.
They actually just left the...
No, he's here.
Look, he's here.
Look at that.
What?
Oh, mom.
Mom, what the fuck?
Hey, mom.
Oh.
I don't want to look at...
What the fuck?
I don't want to look at mom.
That's too much.
No!
Mom, no!
Where's Harold?
Holy shit, the bunny.
Remember the hide-oh, shit, ready, kill.
Oh my god.
Guys, remember how this was a...
So it was maybe a 15-minute level?
I don't really...
All that take me
Most of our memories are new about moving Most of the start
from where I'm moving to How empty it was so please Oh no I
did 14 minutes Oh shit I broke a record guys It only took me
14 minutes To fucking figure out There was a basement To
figure out there was a fucking basement It took me 14
minutes oh my god i'm so good at this game guys I can't
believe it took us that long to finish 15 minute low where's
pace of it all right I can't believe it's still because oh
no autumn sorry don't worry it was just me yelling we're
baby oh we're key don't worry autumn you it's 20 minutes So
that was just me shouting where the fuck's the key and going
around the And like walking around the house 20 times